am montag dem zdf heute live hier an
einem tag wo sehr viel über russland
diskutiert wird denn in der
bundespressekonferenz hat steffen
seibert der bundespressesprecher der
bundesregierung heute das erste mal
zumindest ansatzweise angedeutet dass
bundeskanzlerin merkel sich nicht mehr
gegen sanktionen gegen russland sperrt
ebenfall alexej nawalny der
oppositionelle aus russland der liegt er
seit einiger zeit in der charité mit
vergiftungserscheinungen im künstlichen
koma vor einer knappen dreiviertelstunde
kam dann die eilmeldung aus der charité
dass die ärzte beginnen begonnen haben
damit ihn aus diesem künstlichen koma
herauszuholen und das ja auch
ansprechbar sei wir wollen jetzt über
dieses thema dem zustand von herrn
navalny und auch die frage was das ganze
mit dieser ostseepipeline nord stream 2
zu tun hat in diesem live stream reden
ihr könnt gerne fragen kommentare unten
rein schreiben wir gucken dass wir das
im laufe des livestreams besprechen und
wir freuen uns natürlich auch wenn ihr
den live stream teilt sie gucken aber
jetzt erstmal auf genau diesen fall
alexei navalny da steht mein kollege
carsten behrendt vor der berliner
charité in der hennefer handy liegt
kasten das kannst du uns dann über den
zustand von herrn aber nie sagen ja
deine es gibt eben die positive die
beste neuigkeit der vergangenen zwei
wochen so lange ist er jetzt hier schon
in der charité nämlich dass er aus dem
künstlichen koma aufgeweckt werden
sollte dieses künstliche koma hat die
charité nochmal bestätigt ist die
medikamentöse herbeigeführt worden
das konnte jetzt offensichtlich
gelockert werden bald seinen zustand
sich weiter stabilisiert hat ja und er
reagiert auf ansprache heißt natürlich
noch nicht dass er sprechen kann
erscheint dann offensichtlich auf die
die kontaktaufnahme der ärzte
irgendwelche form von rückmeldungen zu
geben seine frau ist ja auch die ganze
zeit bei ihm und auch sehr enge
vertraute von ihm der nächste schritt
den die charité in einem relativ knappen
aber doch deutlich ein statement
mitgegeben hat es jetzt ihnen von der
künstlichen beatmung zu entwöhnen dass
er also dass seine lunge sich wieder
daran gewöhnt selber zu atmen und er
also weiter sich stabilisiert was die
charité allerdings auch mit gegeben hat
das hat sie in allen ihren bisherigen
statements auch ist das langzeitfolgen
langzeitschäden nicht ausgeschlossen
sind bei alexander wollny
also wir können über seinen wirklichen
zustand und das was diese vergiftung bei
ihm in seinem körper langfristig
verfolgen hat dazu können im moment noch
nichts sagen kannst du kannst du
vielleicht nochmal für uns ja
rekapitulieren wie der ganze fall
eigentlich zustande gekommen ist also
warum und wieso ist herrn auf ein die
eigentlich noch bedienen gekommen ja es
hat eine vorgeschichte es fing mit einem
flug an aus sibirien alexei navalny
beute zurück fliegen
nach moskau hat dann erscheinungen
gezeigt da konnte es nicht nicht mehr
richtig atmen wir haben bilder gesehen
auch von dem flug er fiel in einer
bewusstlosigkeit und der pilot hat dann
eine notlandung eine zwischenlandung
eingelegt in sibirien in uns wohler weil
die dann auch mit dem rettungswagen ins
krankenhaus gekommen ist und wir haben
im nachhinein auch erfahren wenn diese
notlandung nicht die zwischenlandung
nicht herbeigeführt worden wäre hätte er
das mit ziemlicher sicherheit nicht
überlegt also stand dem spitz auf knopf
er wurde dann in omsk behandelt da
entwickelte sich das ganze zu einem
regelrechten krimi dieser verfallen die
die frage ist er vergiftet worden was da
diesen zustand herbeigeführt und es gab
relativ schnell auch das angebot oder
anders es war ein hilferuf der kam von
mitgliedern der
der punk band pussycat die hier in
berlin angefragt haben bei der
organisation cinema for peace ob sie
nicht eine private rettungsorganisation
rettungsaktion führen dabei die
organisieren könnten
das haben sie sehr schnell auf die beine
gestellt mit privaten spendengeldern
einen rettungsflug nach russland
geschickt und das nächste kapitel in
diesem in diesem krimi war daneben wird
da fallen die die freigabe erhalten hier
nach deutschland gebracht zu werden da
hat sich die bundesregierung
eingeschaltet es gab vermittlungsaktion
teilweise auch über bande über finnland
und letztlich hat derweil die dann vor
gut zwei wochen am samstag dann startete
dieser rettungskette überraschend dann
für uns an dem morgen hier richtung
charité dabei die wurde mit
polizeischutz hier eingeliefert das war
wie ein wie ein staatsgast obwohl sich
die bundesregierung dann sehr bemüht hat
zu sagen ein herr navalny ist kein
staatsgast sondern er genießt eine form
von gast rest gastrecht die ihm
letztlich personenschutz des bka zu
kommen lässt also das heißt man hat
schon eine bedrohung auch für herrn
dabei nie hier gesehen und danach hat
die charité dann sich ziemlich in
schweigen gehüllt es gab bislang keine
einzige pressekonferenz zu dem fall
sondern immer nur presse statements die
abgestimmt waren mit seiner familie und
diese statements waren immerhin so dass
wir in denen in diesem wie heute kam das
fünfte in diesen statements
herausgelesen haben dass sich sein
zustand nach und nach verbessert der
größte hammer der letzten zwei wochen
waren natürlich die botschaft dass man
die vergiftet worden sei das kann
relativ schnell bei den
laboruntersuchungen hervor und das
institut der bundeswehr hat er nach
längerer analyse festgestellt dass es
ein kampf gfk in kampfstoff aus der
lobby job gruppe erstmal müssen wir mal
kurz ein haken ich habe das richtig
verstanden hermann wally ist die ganze
zeit unter personenschutz auch in der
charité das heißt man kommt gar nicht so
einfach an ihn heran
das wäre es sowieso nicht so einfach bei
einem patienten der intensivmedizinisch
betreut ist dass man da einfach mal so
hin geht
er ist abgeschirmte nur seine familie
hat
ganz zu ihm seine familie äußert sich
allerdings nicht direkt gegenüber den
medien sondern seine organisation
kommunizierte ausschließlich über ihre
eigenen social media kanäle
das heißt also auch dadurch dass die
charité nur schriftlich mit den
journalisten kommuniziert sind dass die
information an die wir uns halten und
die wir haben nur weitergeben können
also am quelle charité es geht ihm
besser er ist aus dem künstlichen koma
erwacht jetzt gab es ja das heißt sogar
da auch gesagt die meldung oder
zumindest die erkenntnis dass das gift
nicht im mutmasslich vergiftet wurde aus
dieser kampfmittel gruppe nur wie doc
also ein in der sowjetunion entwickelter
kampfstoff stammen soll wurden bislang
eigentlich in welche belege vorgelegt
oder ist das bis jetzt quasi eine
aussage die dort einfach im raum steht
es gibt die aussage des instituts der
bundeswehr des labors dort wir haben
diese laborbefunde nicht vorgelegt
bekommen sondern auch das kam über eine
pressemitteilung und eben aus dem labor
allerdings dem vorausgegangen die
untersuchung aus mehreren laboren die
die charité hat durchgeführt hat also
mittlerweile haben oft nicht nicht
mehrere labore die vergiftung die
vergiftung mit diesen cholinesterase
hemmen bestätigt und konkrete job kann
eben vom labor der bundeswehr so was gab
es hier am wochenende sehr viel
diskussion innerhalb der bundesregierung
auch norbert röttgen der vorsitzende des
auswärtigen ausschusses von der cdu hat
sich da schon mehrfach in den letzten
tagen dazu geäußert was dieser fehler
war nie mit der nordsee-pipeline der
ostseepipeline nord stream 2 zu tun
haben könnte und gestern in der bild am
sonntag gab es noch mal ein statement
dann dazu von heiko maas und heute in
der bundespressekonferenz hat sich dann
das erste mal steffen seibert als
sprecher der bundesregierung
eingeschaltet und hat folgendes dazu
gesagt es ist heute zu früh um ihnen
unsere gemeinsame mit den partnern
gründlich beraten europäische reaktion
hier darzulegen so das klingt vage aber
es klingt nicht nach einem völligen
wir sprechen darüber mit frank buchwald
unserem hauptstadtkorrespondenten im
hauptstadtstudio berlin hatte frank
hallo wie darf man denn jetzt diese paar
sekunden o-ton steffen seibert deuten ja
dass es geht um diese frage sanktionen
wegen navalny da gibt es viele viele
verschiedene stimmen aus dem politischen
berlin heiko maas in einem
zeitungsinterview
gestern am sonntag hat sanktionen nicht
ausgeschlossen auch die kanzlerin hat
das dem vernehmen nach nicht mehr
ausgeschlossen hat steffen seibert hat
heute vormittag in der
bundespressekonferenz gesagt andere sind
da skeptischer und es geht natürlich
immer wieder und sehr deutlich um die
berühmte ostseepipeline nord stream 2
wie kann man das denn überhaupt deuten
das ist da so verschiedene stimmen gibt
norbert röttgen vor lassen dass
auswärtigen ausschusses im bundestag
äußert sich dass er dieses projekt am
liebsten sofort beiseite legen möchte
zumindest pausieren
heiko maas der außenminister äußert sich
in einer ähnlichen art und weise wie
kommt denn das zustande gerade wo merkel
ja immer wieder gesagt hat sie hält an
dieser pipeline fest
das projekt ist immer schon umstritten
gewesen nord stream 2 war niemals
unumstritten
es ist ja eine erdgas pipeline die
direkt aus russland nach deutschland
führt die pipeline soll ankommen oder
kommt an nordstream 1 gibt es ja schon
auf rügen in sassnitz und durch diese
pipeline fließt russisches gas an allen
nachbarländern vorbei direkt nach
deutschland
das hat immer schon bei den
nachbarländern zu großem argwohn geführt
die polen waren von anfang an dagegen
die baltischen staaten waren dagegen
natürlich die ukraine
wir haben gestern mit dem ukrainischen
botschafter gesprochen der sich
angesichts des falles eine wahl die auch
noch mal entschieden gegen das pipeline
projekt ausgesprochen hat also
umstritten war es immer
nun ist diese baustelle aber schon sehr
weit fortgeschritten
diese zweite pipeline die zweite röhre
die liegt fast komplett in der ostsee es
fehlen glaube ich noch etwas mehr als
100 kilometer
dh das sind schon milliarden verbaut
worden und viele sagen natürlich sondern
ein solches milliarden
ein projekt was ja schon fast fertig ist
einfach liegen lassen oder nicht doch
weiterbauen zum beispiel norbert walter
borjans hat das gesagt gestern in berlin
direkt
wir gucken uns vielleicht am besten noch
mal ganz kurz an was es mit dieser
ostseepipeline nord stream zwei
eigentlich auf sich hat und da hat mein
kollege jan friedrich fischer ein
bisschen was zusammengestellt wir uns
nord stream 2 soll von russland nach
lubmin verlaufen die gesamtlänge rund
1200 kilometer parallel zur pipeline
nord stream 1 jährlich könnten so 55
milliarden kubikmeter erdgas nach
deutschland und von dort nach europa
strömen
hinter dem projekt steht der
teilstaatliche russische konzern gazprom
der die hälfte der kosten in höhe von
9,5 milliarden euro trägt die andere
hälfte stammt vom westeuropäische
unternehmen darunter die deutschen
juniper und wintershall der die pipeline
wuchs täglich um drei kilometer 150
fehlen noch doch die arbeiten nun der
grund die usa haben allen firmen die am
bau beteiligt sind mit sanktionen
gedroht die angst europa könnte noch
stärker vom russischen gas abhängig
werden doch deutschland ist auf erdgas
angewiesen es könnte eine überbrückung
technologie für die energiewende sein
bei einem endgültigen stopp der arbeiten
drohen hohe schadensforderungen so also
ganz schön komplex das ganze wir gucken
von einem vergifteten russischen
oppositionellen zum kreml bis hin nach
washington wo sich präsident trampler
eingeschaltet hat um das ganze zu ordnen
gucken wir vielleicht erst mal auf genau
diese frage ob nord stream style zwar
jetzt sterben könnte oder nicht da geht
es einmal ein kommentar von andrea
schmoll hier bei unseren zuschauern der
meint das ganze sei eine scheinheilige
diskussion
es sei nicht bewiesen aber wenn in saudi
arabien gilt also die sportlehrerin
großen enthauptet oder ausgepeitscht
wird dann juckt das also ganz schön ist
das ganze nicht von einem vergisst sich
in russischen oppositionellen eigentlich
abgedrückt haben aber frank buchwald die
frage geht an sie ist das ganze
scheinheilig diese diskussion wenn man
jetzt über sanktionen gegen russland
nachdenkt wegen eines mutmaßlich
vergifteten opposition
in saudi arabien nie was sagt und das öl
einfach stillschweigend entgegennimmt
nun ist es ja nicht so dass man in saudi
arabien nie was gesagt hat also nach dem
mord an car show qi wir erinnern uns der
ist ja im generalkonsulat im saudischen
in istanbul offensichtlich zu tode
gekommen unter ungeklärten umständen
aber es scheint doch relativ
unumstritten das wohl tatsächlich
saudische sicherheitsleute diese diesen
mord begangen haben danach hatte es
erhebliche sanktionen gegen saudi
arabien gegeben
ob das jetzt scheinheilig ist also da
möchte ich hier keine
das würde ich jetzt so nicht bestätigen
es ist so dass diese pipeline ebene
umstritten war und washington es ist
nicht nur präsident trump der sich
dagegen ausgesprochen hat auch die
demokraten auch demokratische senatoren
haben dieses projekt scharf kritisiert
hier gibt es eine andere statement von
andreas potthoff der meinten nord stream
2 kann gar nicht in frage gestellt
werden denn im kalten krieg haben die
deutschen auch gas von der wirtin
bekommen ich lese aus diesem kommentar
so ein bisschen heraus wir sind auf das
gas aus dem osten im grunde angewiesen
sonst funktioniert das hier überhaupt
nicht mehr mit der energie versorgung
ist das tatsächlich so frank buchwald ob
deutschland nun unbedingt auf das
russische gas angewiesen ist dass durch
nord stream zwei eines tages vielleicht
fließen wird das ist eine frage die
schwer zu beantworten ist es können
experten beantworten die sprecherin des
bundeswirtschaftsministeriums war da
heute in der bundespressekonferenz
relativ zugeknöpft nun ist es so dass
deutschland große große gasreserven hat
also zur not könnte deutschland monate
oder völlig ohne zusätzliche
gaslieferungen auskommen ein großteil
des gases das im deutschen gasnetz
strömt kommt aus norwegen
man kann gas verflüssigen und mit
tankschiffen aus aller welt nach europa
bringen zum beispiel bekommen wir meines
wissens gas aus katar auf diesem weg und
auch aus den usa möglicherweise also es
gibt zahlreiche andere versorgungswege
sodass nach einschätzung vieler die
versorgungssicherheit in deutschland
nicht gefährdet wäre
werden nord stream zahlen nicht zustande
kommt und viele argumentieren auch
ökologisch die grünen zum beispiel sagen
dass gas als fossile brennstoff ja nun
mit der energiewende sowie so
verschwinden werde
bis 2050 will deutschland co2 neutral
sein das heißt es wird dann wohl auch
kein gas mehr verbrannt und sie stellen
dieses projekt auch deshalb in frage
weil sie sagen im grunde ist das eine
überholte technik aber tatsächlich die
deutsche wirtschaft argumentiert und
sagt das hat immer funktioniert mit den
russen auch zu zeiten des kalten krieges
als es noch viel viel schwieriger war
als heute da ist kein problem aber
tatsächlich ist es natürlich so andere
die gegner die befürworter eines
baustopps argumentieren man darf den
russen das jetzt nicht durchgehen lassen
man muss da eine karte gegen sanktionen
setzen und die härteste von ahlen ist
natürlich ein solches milliardenprojekt
scheitern zu lassen aber viele deutsche
firmen sind beteiligt also da gehen
nicht nur russische milliarden sozusagen
verloren sondern auch viele viele
milliarden deutsche unternehmen ähnlich
kommt ja auch gerade einen kommentar bei
youtube vom user kw der mine sanktionen
kann man ändern nord stream 2 ist eine
knallharte strafe also da quasi das
ganze projekt abzusägen die nicht ohne
weiteres mehr rückgängig zu machen ist
ist das tatsächlich so dass das die
einzige ultima ratio ist die
bundesregierung jetzt hat was gäbe ist
noch an alternativen
die alternativen sind natürlich
persönliche senkt sanktionen gegen
bestimmte politiker in russland
da kann man konten einfrieren und
reisesperren verhängen das ist das
übliche instrumentarium was man in
solchen fällen gelegentlich anwendet
aber ein wirkliches fanal ein starker
ein starkes signal wäre natürlich
tatsächlich der baustopp bei dieser
ostseebad ich bin kein experte für den
bau von pipelines aber ob das projekt
damit sozusagen endgültig ich sag's mal
salopp abgesoffen ist das kann ich nicht
beurteilen das kann ja sehr wohl seien
die bauarbeiten sind ja bereits seit
einiger zeit unterbrochen
es wird also gegenwärtig gar nicht mehr
gebaut an dieser pipeline
das kann man möglicherweise auch
verschließen und irgendwann wieder
aufnehmen und der sprecher des
bundesumweltministeriums sprach heute in
der bundespressekonferenz auf fragen von
journalisten nach dem wert einer solchen
pipeline jenseits von 2.050 davon
man könnte ja auch ganz andere gase in
einer solchen pipelines transportieren
etwa künstlich hergestelltem wasserstoff
also ob das nun ein endgültiges aus und
ein nicht zu revidieren da schritt ist
mit der ostseepipeline das kann ich
nicht beurteilen aber ich habe den
eindruck ganz so endgültig ist es dann
doch nicht
frank buchwald vielen dank für ihre
antworten und einschätzungen wir müssen
jetzt leider hier einen deckel drauf
machen denn die 17 uhr heute nachrichten
brauchen das studio
ich bedanke mich erstmal für ihre
antworten und ihre staaten und ihre
kommentare hier und ich denke das ganze
wird es ziemlich spannend bleiben ganz
kurze anmerkung noch ein user auf
youtube fragt er wegen des patts gerade
ob das ganze hier live ist oder
aufgezeichnet nein das ist ein live
stream
wir senden tatsächlich direkt auf eure
endgeräte das heißt wir bleiben auch
dran das nächste mal sehen wir uns nie
etwas passiert vielen dank bis hierhin
und tschüss